il ya 20 ans la grande innovation de la
campagne présidentielle c'était d'avoir
un site internet waouh
[Musique]
cette semaine on revient sur les
innovations dans les campagnes
présidentielle et en 2002 c'était le
tout début des sites internet des
candidats ça donnait ça que faisait tout
en 2002 sur la toile autres
présidentielle autre époque autre
méthode en 2002 celle esquisse des
premiers sites de campagnes
révolutionnaires à l'époque ils sont
aujourd'hui d'un autre temps surtout au
niveau design du html pur juste une
biographie du candidat quelques données
de son programme et une zone contact par
mail évidemment voilà c'était un petit
peu basique mais en 2007 le site
internet devient vraiment le vaisseau
amiral d'une campagne présidentielle et
le candidat centriste françois bayrou
mise beaucoup là dessus pour françois
bayrou l'internet est un moyen de sortir
des frontières partisanes il n'est pas
possible que ça soit perpétuellement 2
au détail deux seuls qui soient
présentés privilégié mis en vedette dans
les médias
internet est un moyen de résistance
comme un citron à quel coquin ans se
prend sa bayrou cinq ans plus tard la
politique entre dans l'ère des réseaux
sociaux les candidats vent sur twitter
facebook pour communiquer directement
avec leurs électeurs et puis les jeux
vidéo s'empare aussi de la
présidentielle la course à la présidence
en version jeu vidéo élections 2012 en
route pour l'elysée désormais les
internautes peuvent se lancer dans la
campagne depuis chez eux pour devenir le
futur maître du château le jeu propose
un choix de personnages candidats vous
êtes plutôt de gauche choisissent et
laurent norvège de l'aes plutôt de
droite avec guillaume comme ati et son
eu d'aidé ou encore communiste avec jean
paul ii buchon ensuite vous devez
parcourir les routes de france jouer
avec les sondages et les journalistes
gérer votre budget de campagne le jeu a
ses limites avec un visuel 3d un peu
ringard et des imitations de voix tout
de même bien tenté j'aimerais bien vous
entendre sur ce sujet on pourra trouver
peut-être un peu de réalisme dans
l'option coups fourrés rumeurs petites
phrases tout y est pour entrer dans le
jeu politique on va maintenant vous
montrer une pépite darchy politique en
2012 jean-luc mélenchon lance sa web
série pour raconter sa campagne épisode
par épisode et sa websérie il l'a elle
en marche
les l'histoire politique a parfois
beaucoup d'ironie alors il faut
reconnaître qu'à chaque campagne
présidentielle les équipes de jean luc
mélenchon sont très innovante et en 2017
elle lance les fameux meeting en
hologramme le 5 février dernier jean luc
mélenchon sort le grand jeu en proposant
le premier meeting en hologramme mardi
prochain il sera physiquement à dijon et
en hologrammes dans six autres villes
sept meetings au même moment tous les
candidats en ont rêvé et pour cette
campagne 2022 le candidat de la france
insoumise va encore plus loin avec des
meetings immersif et olfactif et puis
comme d'autres candidats il s'est lancé
sur twitter la plateforme de streaming
ou les politiques tentent de s'adresser
aux jeunes
[Musique]